soir gérald olivier merci d'être avec
nous avant d'évoquer cette politique qui
pourrait changer au moyen-orient mon
tout d'abord sur ces sondages favorables
évidemment au début de mandat souvent
pour joe biden le classique état de
grâce où une autre explication qui
serait lié à donald trump
écoutez c'est difficile à dire pour
l'instant toujours est il que joe biden
est en train de mettre en place sa
politique et c'est d'abord une politique
qui se veut en rupture avec celle de
donald trump
on l'a vu avec la série de décrets qu'il
a signé depuis une semaine dont
l'essentiel sont en fait constitue à
détricoter ce qu'avait mis en place
donald trump
alors il a des sondages favorables parce
que pour l'instant comment dirais-je
il plaît à son électorat c'est à dire
que lorsqu'il promet de régulariser 11
millions de clandestins
eh bien il plaît à l'ailé gauche du
parti démocrate qui veut des frontières
ouvertes
lorsqu'il promet ou même lorsqu'il fait
interrompre le projet de pipeline qui
stones ou qu'il suspend les permis pour
le la fracturation hydraulique ce qu'on
appelle le fracking en anglais ou bien
encore qu'il suspend les permis
d'exploration pour les énergies fossiles
il plaît à l'est l'environnementaliste
écologistes du parti démocrate et
peut-être c'est ce qu'on constate dans
les sondages
maintenant le fond de la politique n'est
pas encore en place et par contre on ne
peut pas gouverner éternellement par
décret donc à un moment il faudra qu'ils
s'arrêtent
il faudra que peut-être il regarde ce
qui se passe du côté du congrès où après
tout les démocrates ont une majorité
donc rien n'empêche de passer par le
législateur mais c'est vrai qu'à partir
de là les choses seront moins simple
alors comment justement réagissent et
républicains quand ils voient la
politique de donald trump être
détricoter avec la sortie évidemment que
l'on sait un de leur poule a ils font
profil bas aux états unis en fait ce qui
se passe c'est que les républicains sont
en train de dénoncer
un discours qui se veut un discours
unificateur rappelons-nous de l'appel
lancé par joe biden il ya à peine plus
d'une semaine lors de son discours
d'investiture il dénonce ce discours
avec des actes qui eux sont plutôt
provocateur
parce qu'encore une fois lorsque vous
promettez de régulariser 11 millions de
clandestins c'est un chiffon rouge qui
est agité devant les supporter de donald
trump qui étaient massivement contre
l'immigration notamment l'immigration
clandestine
lorsque vous lorsque vous interrompez un
projet comme le projet d'oléoduc
keystone vous allez contre la politique
de donald trump qui servait à relancer
le secteur de l'énergie et à relancer
des emplois industriels aux états unis
et on pourrait comme ça énuméré d'autres
décisions qui ont été prises et qui vont
à l'encontre de tout ce que les
supporters de donald trump défendent est
donc prêcher l'unité d'un côté mais de
l'autre côté prendre des décisions qui
sont interprétées comme des provocations
par 75 millions d'électeurs il ya une
contradiction fondamentale et c'est
celle qui pour l'instant est dénoncé de
manière relativement timide parce que
les républicains sont eux mêmes pris à
un autre piège dont on parlera peut-être
un petit peu plus tard mais qui est
quand même soutenu est mise en avant par
un certain nombre de médias et d'élus
républicains alors la politique au
moyen-orient à anthony blinken a à la
détailler aujourd'hui peut-on parler
d'une véritable remise à plat alors
qu'on sait quand même qu'il ya eu des
succès dans ce domaine
l'ancien président trump mais justement
justement c'est votre remarque est
parfaitement justifiée on ne veut pas
forcément en donner crédit au président
trump mais il a malgré tout ouvert les
yeux alors sur la chine d'un côté mais
au proche orient il a clairement mis en
évidence je dirais les manquements de ce
compte de ce qu'on appelait le jessy pi
au est le fameux accord sur le nucléaire
iranien ou il a souligné que cet accord
n'avait pas du tout priver l'iran de
pouvoir parvenir à réaliser une bombe
nucléaire sade et simplement le retarder
donc aujourd'hui quand anthony blinken
vous parle de rétablir un dialogue avec
l'iran
il ne le fait pas sur la base qui était
celle de l'accord il le fait en
profitant de ce que la rupture donald
trump a mis en place même chose sur la
politique je dirais proche orientale il
ne remet pas en cause des accords de
brahms personne n'a le donner crédit à
donald trump
je crois qu'il a eu deux propositions
pour recevoir le prix nobel de la paix
pour ses accords peut-être que le temps
démontrera que ce sont des accords de
paix fondamentaux parce qu'ils ont
changé la donne au proche orient
mais anthony blinken le secrétaire
d'état prend bien soin de ne pas
détricoter cela est de parler d'une
nouvelle politique
alors c'est vrai plus multilatéraliste
plus porté sur le dialogue mais qui
quand même profitent de certains acquis
mises en place pendant quatre ans par
donald trump dans l'administration alors
un autre changement sur les armes un
washington qui suspend temporairement
certains transferts et vante encore de
matériel de défense américains comme
l'arabie saoudite et les émirats arabes
unis sauf sauf erreur de ma part que
donald trump avait passé des accords en
échange de la reconnaissance par les
émirats bhl de l'état d'israël oui ça
c'est une c'est une décision qui ont en
effet pu poser problème parce qu on en
revient toujours à quelque chose qu'on
avait dénoncé du temps de donald trump
c'est à dire jusqu'à quel point les
engagements d'une administration doivent
être respectées par l'administration qui
vient après on a cela pour ceux se
cette livraison d'armes ou cet achat
d'armes comme comme vous le disiez
qu'ils portaient quand même sur 100
milliards et qui avait contribué
grandement à je dirais facile
et et l'intercession de l'arabie
saoudite dans justement ce nouveau
processus de paix au proche orient
et là on a une administration qui fait
comme si cet accord n'existait pas donc
on a des questions à se poser sur la
continuité de la politique américaine
il fut un temps où cette continuité
était quand même plus assurée notamment
en matière de politique étrangère d'une
administration à l'autre géant le vivier
vous m'aviez invité a justement parlé de
ce piège dans lequel les républicains se
sont mis ce sera ma dernière question
quel est ce piège justement le piège
c'est le piège tendu par
l'administration démocrate concernant le
procès de donald trump le procès en
destitution
c'est à dire que depuis le 6 janvier
sous prétexte de l'envahissement du
capitole par certains des supporters de
donald trump ce jour là eh bien on
dénonce aux états unis la montée d'un
extrémisme
la présence de ce qu'ils appellent des
dom sd terroriste intérieure des
domestiques et on prétend aujourd'hui je
dirais nettoyer le pays des trois y est
l'armé nettoyer les villes et des
provinces de cette présence de gens
qu'on assimile à des suprématistes
blancs à des terroristes et qui sont en
fait des supporters de donald trump est
en vérité on constate avec la présence
de troupes à washington qui n'est
absolument plus justifiée l'investiture
c'était il ya une semaine
ça a fait venir 26 mille soldats je
crois que plus de la moitié sont
toujours présents à washington
on a les images d'une ville en état de
siège pour maintenir cette fiction cette
illusion qui lie à une menace et en
profiter pour faire monter un nouveau
maccarthysme et ces hamacs artistes qui
piège les républicains dans une sorte de
je dirais de paradoxes totalitaires ou
orwelliens parce que aujourd'hui à
washington
si vous dénoncez cette attaque contre
les supporters de 36 vous dénoncer ces
abus contre un certain nombre de
libertés
eh bien vous est pointé du doigt comme
ayant pris la défense de ces extrémistes
et êtes vous-même partisans de cet
extrémiste donc vous êtes partisan de
vous menacer d'état et et c'est
exactement ce qui se passait
les années 50 avec mac car si à l'époque
on prétendait nettoyer le gouvernement
de l' influence communiste et il fallait
faire passer des tests aux employés
fédéraux pour s'assurer qu'ils n'avaient
pas chez eux des amis des connaissances
qui étaient proches du parti communiste
et si c'était le cas et bien ils étaient
évincés
et si vous vous même vous preniez la
défense de ces gens là et bien vous
étiez accusés d'être complices de ces
communistes c'est exactement la même
chose à laquelle on assiste aujourd'hui
ou si vous prenez la défense des
supporters de trump on vous accuse
d'être le complice de terrorisme
domestique et c'est un climat que je
considère extrêmement malsain et c'est
de ce piège là dont je parlais en
évoquant les républicains et un certain
silence par rapport à ce qui est en
train de se dérouler merci beaucoup
gérald olivier d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur arte france